how are you guys doing hi how are you
where are you I'm actually in Brazil I'm
at a convention called ccxp which is one
of the biggest Comic Cons in the world
and I've been there
I was gonna say I was gonna be like
exactly so for people that don't realize
what do you want to tell people about
speed because you understand this yes I
loved that it was one of the best
experience I've ever had the fans were
incredible yeah you can also you can you
know what I mean you can see how it's
it's it's uh I was going to curse it's
kind of nuts yeah I'll say it like that
but listen I want to start with um
congratulations uh you're both so good
in the movie
um I think uh this Tom Hanks is gonna
have a career he's going to land on his
feet
you think so I don't know
exactly
but I'm I'm being uh serious uh Mariana
I'm I can't believe you were the same
person I saw in narcos Mexico like
you're I I couldn't I couldn't believe
it when I was prepping to talk to you I
was like this is not the same woman no
way so I just want to get I want to give
you huge props because it's uh you know
what I mean but yeah thank you
Manuel I'm sort of curious um Tom I read
that Tom suggested you for this role
after you worked with him previously and
you're you can sometimes be known as a
serious action person and this is such a
different role for you when someone gets
you a role like this what do you get
them as a gift
well well
first of all yes you're right uh when I
first you know if for me it's very hard
to do comedy or at least for me I I feel
like I'm not confident enough to do it
but then I've heard that Tom was like no
Manuel will this bring Manuel and I'm
like if Tom says I have to do it you
know um but yeah I did give him first of
all a lot of thanks and and I did bring
him uh you know
remember when the conversation
for the table like the tablecloth oh
yeah
yeah because he was telling me about his
house so I bring him and Rita some
presents
the key light drop in there as well
um what was it about the scripted
material that said I really need to do
this
well obviously because Tom and Mark were
attached to the project and it's like a
dream come true to work with both of
them
uh and uh and it was just like a
a beautiful it is a beautiful script the
the novel is
uh amazing and I think it was very
faithful what David McGee did and
transformed for for the film
and it's just a beautiful story that
speaks uh to all of us at this moment
and
um speaks about Community about finding
your own family and and we have become
isolated with the pandemic a lot and
fragmented in so many ways that I think
it's a good moment to see these these
films yeah I think so too I mean for me
it was the people involved you know Tom
saying that you know inviting me of
course I always wanted to work with with
Mark Forster I met him a few years back
and I told him I you know I loved his
work and I wanted to work with him
sometime so that was that this story and
also I want to bring my mom to a movie
that she's not there's no guns and no
you know like something that she would
be like crying and you know so uh yeah
because it's just a beautiful story so
so I'm I'm really proud
um to be part of this I love cats and uh
this film has a cat and I'm just curious
if you I'm one just wondering do you
think the more one of the morals of the
movie is a cat can help save your life
totally it saves mine every day I have
three cats and and uh well I I love that
aspect because they do
comfort me and just they're my
companions of life and
um and I and I love them and I just love
that auto finds finds their savior the
Savior and them yeah
I I love that aspect of the film
um I love talking about people's careers
and what they've done and the question I
like asking a lot of people for both of
you is when you think back on all the
projects you've worked on what shot like
what specific shot ended up being the
toughest one that you've been a part of
oh I don't know for me for me uh
for me I think it's been uh doing
Michael Bay six underground uh
rolling on a car
you know being strapped on things and
just rolling and rolling and rolling you
know that was uh one of the toughest
things I've ever done I've got
claustrophobic
so you know being tied into the car just
going like this over and over and over I
think that was the toughest thing
yeah well I I just worked on a on a
series called Cecilia and there was a
there's a scene where she has kind of a
breakdown a bit of a psychotic you know
breakdown in a very important family
meeting
and it was challenging you know
challenging to kind of go into that
state and then reel back and do it again
I mean it was uh it was emotionally
challenging but it was very rewarding
because all the work that was done
previously led to that moment it was
like the emotional
uh pivot and when it's done and when you
do it
along with everybody else it just feels
so rewarding and uh yeah it was
difficult but it was very rewarding
obviously like everyone and I'm sure
both of you uh I think Tom Hanks is just
an amazing such a talented actor and um
he makes me believe I mean he could read
the phone book and I would want to watch
it so I'm just curious I'm I'm so
seriously what what is it like watching
someone like that up close because he's
such a professional and he is not a diva
and he's you know what I mean like so
what what is it like really working with
someone like that and what do you take
away from it to bring to your own work
going forward
mm-hmm
Japan
time
I mean I mean for me it was a
it is my second film with him and it's
just I can't emphasize it or I can't
just is I my brain doesn't take like I
can't understand how a character or a
person like this huge star Tom Hanks can
be
you know
this
it should be like that but this humble
and this uh this welcoming and this uh
you know um
and I think he he he wrote he's the
captain of the boat so whatever he
brings into the set you know the energy
that he brings the attitude that he
brings that's the way everybody you know
so that's why I think I mean especially
the two films that I've been with them
they they work so nicely because you
know his his the energy that he brings
is is what you know everyone's in the
same page
yeah and um and he really the scenes
that we worked like he is so truthful
all the time he works from a place of
just truth and he can portray it so
um not effortless you know but it's just
it comes out with such sincerity in the
moment and and he's a generous actor he
stands there with you and he gives you
everything even if it's your take and
and you know if it was my he would be
working completely open his heart was
like you know and
and so so working with
so much truth all the time and he
happens to be a genius in every sense
he's so smart and he's so resourceful in
every possible way and all that goes
into his performance and so to be the
recipient of all those contents
uh it just kind of uh makes your
performance better obviously in any way
I mean it's just such a blessing yeah on
that note I need to go thank you so much
for your time thank you and enjoy your
afternoon thank you thank you Brazil